haha the Joe Rogan experience can you do
that while I talk about my new specials
coming up hey tiger speaking of animals
why'd you come to my paper tiger because
I just think we're in a hilarious time
cuz you already took strange time I have
to stop say like I like the amount of
times I had to stop saying it's so weird
times it's John's it's the name of Joe
special because it just is like what
we're focusing on like oh my god can you
[ __ ] believe is well this real like
half the [ __ ] that's going on if it's
true it's like you could make a Will
Smith or a Tom Cruise movie on those
end-of-the-world movies where they
accept you know it's not gonna have a
happy ending and it's just like it just
kind of strikes me I don't know and it
was also I just I wanted people to watch
it and have fun like I'm not trying to
[ __ ] hurt anybody it's not malicious
but I'm doing my job I'm talking about
what's in the news and I'm [ __ ]
around and it sparked that and then the
other part is just me I'm talking about
my flaws my temper and trying to work
that [ __ ] out that's all this [ __ ]
thing is and for some reason not just
saying stand up just a lot of [ __ ] that
is not as far as like if you had
priorities you know like if your house
just burnt down you're not being like
god we have to get a new toaster you
know it's like now we need shelter like
that's the number one thing but there's
all this [ __ ] that's like you know a
line of importance like line 42 is is
getting gassed up to likes number seven
or number eight or something like that
and I already know people are gonna be
like you know typical white male cuz you
can't like all of that [ __ ] you know
that there's just something funny about
how overtly I don't know I guess reverse
like it's like you're doing the same
[ __ ] thing and you don't even realize
you're doing it as you're saying like a
lot some groups of people not all of
them like I've been joking how like a
lot of feminists are like smart but it's
not the ones that are on TV
it's like sports fans a lot of sports
fans are really smart but not the ones
that call in sports talk radio
that's perfect you don't I mean yes it's
like when we when we would do the Opie
and Anthony show okay like Howard Stern
like when he would do back in the day
when he would do live remotes I love
Howard Stern I love opening it that he
put like if I was a fan of this show I
don't have time and I'm not going to
some [ __ ] mall in the middle of the
day blowing off work or whatever the
[ __ ] is I'm trying to get my own [ __ ]
going the people that show up you love
them because they're diehards but
they're out of their [ __ ] minds so it
just has to do with that I'm kind of it
doesn't necessarily have to do with me
but it does it's one of one of those
things and it's also another way of
saying that I'm full of [ __ ]
and you're a paper tiger yeah exactly
exactly so
[Applause]